>> MCMULLAN: Good morning everybody. Thank
you for attending this session. I know you
guys have a lot of choices and sessions and
we really appreciate you coming by to hear
our session this morning. So my name is Scott
McMullan. I'm the Google Apps partner lead
with the Google Enterprise Group, work with
the Marketplace team as well. And today, we're
going to be talking about the Google Apps
Marketplace. And this is going to be a fairly
high level session. We're not going to go
into a lot of technical depth. This is designed
to give you an overview of how the Marketplace
works, some of the motivations of how we built
it, and most importantly, hear from a few
folks on the Marketplace who are launch partners,
who--and hear how they're doing. Get some
tips from them and really get the kind of
the word in the street. So I've got Amit Kulkarni,
CEO of ManyMoon with me, Chuck Dietrich, CEO
of SlideRocket, and Jay Simons, VP of Marketing
at Atlassian. So now we've got our WiFi setup
and we can actually run all the steps from
the Cloud. Quick housekeeping bit.ly/SellWithMarketplace,
this is our Google Wave for this session.
This is where we ask you to ask questions
and we'll take these at the very end. Okay.
So, the Google Apps Marketplace--before we
get into that, let's do a quick level set
on Google Apps. This is definitely a source
of confusion for a lot of folks. Google Apps
is our hosted messaging and collaborations
suite designed for businesses and organizations
of all sizes. So it includes a suite of applications,
most of which, hopefully, you’ve heard of,
so Gmail, Calendar, Talk, Google Sites, Google
Groups, Google Docs which includes spreadsheets
and documents, all these things in a suite
designed for organizations of all sizes. We
work with small, medium, and large businesses
as well as non-profits and EDUs. So the two
ways to get this if you are an EDU, or if
you're a smaller company under 50 users, you
can use our free edition, our [INDISTINCT]
edition. Or if you're a business or fall outside
of that organization class, you can use our
premier edition. It's $50 a user a year product.
And we're super gratified to see in the last
three years what customers and what the, you
know, users out there have done with this
product. We've got over 25 million active
users to date. That’s across 2 million businesses.
And we got more than 3,000 businesses signing
up each day for these products. So we're very
gratified. We think this is just the beginning
of what we can do here. Quick note, the logos
on the slide are bare companies, Motorola,
Voleo, Konica Minolta. But for the purposes
of today and the discussion about the Marketplace,
you should be thinking more in terms of the
SMBs, the SMB segment of our customer base.
So, why did we build the Marketplace? It's
pretty simple. Customers want more apps. We've
got our seven or eight. They want to run more
of their business in the Cloud and there's
tons of great stuff out there. We want to
make it really easy to work with the best
Web apps out in the ecosystem and make it
very simple to bring those Web applications
into our customer base and give those easy
access to our users. So simply put, the goal
in Marketplace is to make it easy for customers
to add more great apps to their Google Apps
suite. This is across all kind of segments,
all kinds of verticals, all kinds of used
cases. It can be accounting, sales and marketing
productivity, workflow. It can be big suites,
it can be small applications to do a very
specific purpose. The goal here is to make
it easy for you all to get access and to serve
these customers as they grow. And we are really
lucky that Marketplace launched about months
ago at the Campfire One in Mountain View.
We're really lucky to work with 50 great launch
partners. You'd probably recognized some of
the logos and the people that we launched
with. The key point here and I think I want
you take away is that we've got everything
from start ups to public companies. Everything
from, you know, again, full suites whether
you're a developer suite or a suite for a
business or an ERP or CRM, all the way down
to smaller point products that accomplish
a very specific task. So this is the type
of opportunity, the type of company we're
attracting to work with to bring--to serve
the Google Apps customer base. Okay. So, that’s
very high level of a little bit of why we
built it and some of the people who we launched
with. Let me switch to a quick demo to show
you the user experience what it's like when
we say and make it easy for users and for
customers to get more apps for Google Apps.
So here's the Marketplace, we've got categories
in the left including product and professional
services in the Marketplace can be found.
We've got featured Apps that rotate through
in the center. A set of top apps of the right
based on usage and ratings. And let's say
today that I'm looking for a project management
app for my organization. So we search on project
management, get a list of users--Amit, congratulations.
You're the top search result here. Let's take
a look at ManyMoon. Let's just dive into the
listing. I can look at all the listings here.
Let's pick ManyMoon to get quick look. Again,
I can read about the application. I can get
links to videos. I can read about ratings
or reviews about what the community thinks.
And let's say, based on this, I'm interested
in acquiring this application and trying it
up for my business. So here's where it all
starts. It's basically the Add It Now button.
To click Add It Now and I'm entering my Google
Apps domain. In this case, it’s my kind
of friends and family ehic.com domain. Now
this is a standard edition domain of, again,
the Marketplace is for all of our users, not
just to our premier edition users. So the
first thing it's going to ask me to do is
to sign in. Only admins can install applications
to the Marketplace today. So I'm going to
login it as an admin. Okay, I'm now in the
control panel of my Google Apps for ehic.com.
The first thing I get is the terms of service.
These are ManyMoon's terms of service. So
review these. Send this off to all my lawyers.
Everything is cool. I'm going to hit agree.
I agree and continue. Step two, grant access.
So I'm installing this application and ManyMoon
is a web application who wants to integrate
in with Google Apps. They want to do a lot
of--provide a lot of valuable features to
let me use my Calendars, my Document, et cetera
in the context of project management. So they
are requesting here different APIs that they
want to have access to. I can review them.
And you can see that they’ve got quite a
few there. They're a pretty deeply integrated
product. Once I agree and think I trust these
guys which I do, I'm going to grant my data
access and then, enable the application. So
I'm now just taking ManyMoon product and add
it to the Google App suite. I click over here
on the dashboard, you see that in addition
to the setting, the applications from Google,
I now have ManyMoon--the ManyMoon icon here
and I can do some basic administration here,
as well as a link off to their site. So that’s
the admin experience. That’s browsing--essentially
buying. In this case, it's a premium product
s o they'll charge me later in installing
the application. Let's take a look at what
the user would see. So--Amit will go into
more detail here, but this is the canonical
use of integration that all Marketplace Apps
have which is the single sign on from our
universal navigation. So up here in the very
left, I'm in my Gmail account for my ehic.com
domain and I can easily go to my Google Calendar
and it will open up a new tab. In this case,
I want to go to ManyMoon. So I go to the More
Menu. I see that ManyMoon is now available
to my end-users. I click on that and I'm in.
No passwords, nothing to set up, no account--essentially,
the suite hasn’t been expanded to include
ManyMoon and now I can just start using this
application as an end-user. So that is the
quick high level tool. How does this work?
As a developer, how do you go about getting
your application to Marketplace? How much
effort is required, et cetera? So, the first
thing is you got to build your application.
You'll notice that 50 launch partners; I think
the majority of those were existing applications.
So you can take an existing App. You can build
a new App. There are no platform requirements
or hosting requirements. This is not about
AppEngine or anything else. Even though we
love AppEngine, this is about Web applications.
So you take your Web application. You bring
it to us and you start to integrate it. Very
quickly, there are a number of talks later
on today and tomorrow about deep integration
that go into the mechanics of how this works.
But at a high level, the first thing to do,
again, is use OpenID to enable a single sign-in
experience. That’s where all applications
must do to get the Marketplace, beyond that,
we have over a dozen integration points and
APIs, again, things like Calendar and Contacts
and Docs. Just yesterday, we released Gmail
contextual gadgets which allow you to bring
your application right into the viewing--the
viewer of Gmail. So a bunch of ways you can
integrate, that’s all optional. And then
the last thing and the most important part--this
is a Marketplace, so selling. Again, over
2 million businesses, over 25 million users
and the growing group of resellers with over
1,000 resellers worldwide and growing and
they're increasingly interested in working
with Marketplace Apps and ISVs to build and
pull together brighter solutions for customers.
So that’s a second part of the opportunity
here. And for this, what do we ask? We ask
for two things, a one-time fee of $100 that
allows you to list one or more applications
to Marketplace; and then if you sell your
App--it's not a free app, if you sell your
app, we ask for a 20% share of revenue on
new customers that you acquire through Marketplace.
So you can bring your old customers and they
can all get these integrations but for new
customers who come in and discover and purchase
through the Marketplace, we ask for 20% reg
share recurring. Quick note, that’s not--we're
not doing reg share right now. We'll be rolling
this out later on the second half of this
year when we introduce our Google check out
Marketplace billing APIs which will be required
to continue in the Marketplace. Okay. So,
moving quickly here. How does this work? Build,
integrate, list and sell--these are the three
steps. So we know the build step. You guys
do integrate. Two applications in the Web,
they want to work together, they want to form
a virtual suite. You know that that Google
certainly launched these applications one
by one. You know, Gmail was the first, Docs
came later. These are Web applications that
are working together as one. So the integration
step is very important. And what we do here
is have a simple XML file that you use to
describe all the different integration points
that your application have, both at the business
level like what your terms of service, what
are your policies, what are your privacy policies,
those links in here; as well as the APIs you
need access to. So if you need to have access
to a user's Calendar, you can request that
in these manifest file. You package all this
stuff up and just describe the entire integration.
So how do you actually get in the Marketplace
to start working? Two forms to fill out essentially--the
first is to become a vendor. I think it's
eight fields, you know, what logo, cost of
company name, address, your vendor account.
That’s obviously free and then you click
a button to create a listing. This listing
is--the majority of listing is the marketing,
right? We're basically merchandising your
applications, so benefits and name and category
and things like that. But in order to get
the magic to work around adding it now and
the provisioning of this so you can facilitate
buying, in the lower left here is this manifest
field. This is where you'd paste this XML
file that describes the integration. And what
that allows us to do is then render your page,
not only about your marketing copy but the
Add It Now flow. It will all just kind of
work as I show with installing ManyMoon. Okay,
so you’ve got your listing. You're in. You've
tested it and now, of course, let's launch.
Let's get out there in front of customers.
This is where the real fun begins. One thing
I just wanted to highlight here is to not
skip your launch marketing. If you do choose
to work with us, it really get out there two
months. We don’t have a lot of history here
but we definitely have noticed some folks
have skipped this step and I think it's a
missed opportunity. So, you know, high quality
listing pages; high quality landing pages
on your site, again, what you're essentially
selling into an audience that is a Google
Apps user base with 25 million users. They
have a certain mental model about what to
expect and so you're communicating to them
in that language is important to getting their
attention. And certainly, blogging and tweeting
and doing PR in press.reach are all things
that you should be considering on the launch.
So post-launch, you know, you're out there
and you start to see some its interest and
pageviews, some orders come in, what does
that customer acquisition lifecycle look like?
So it's a funnel, just like what you're doing
today, and no surprise, you know, we're driving
traffic to the Marketplace. If you’ve got
listing pageviews, you're hopefully driving
traffic there as well. We have an "Add it
now" call to action to get people to adopt.
Now they may be in trial mode, they maybe
in buy mode, you know, it depends on what
your application is, but the goal here, of
course, is to drive App usage within the domain
because, again, you're not just selling to
the administrator, you're selling to, potentially,
10, 20, 50, 100, 1000, however big the company
is, you have a bunch of users potentially
have your product. So there are a bunch of
tricks and--not tricks, but there are a bunch
of basic techniques for making sure that the
admin can communicate out the message. That’s
important things to think about as you drive
users to use your product and try to convert
them to paid usage. And so, along that line,
we really--we get a lot of--the point of first
question now is get after I'd described how
this all works is--hey that’s great, Google.
You can put us up there, but how do you drive
awareness just on the Marketplace? How are
your customers going to know about what you're
doing and what we're doing and they end up
with you. So I'm going to give you a very
quick tour, the last couple of minutes of
my talk here about some of the tactics that
we used to drive users in awareness of the
Marketplace and the vendors in the Marketplace.
So, first, inside our products--so, for example,
in the upper left in that universal navigation,
you'll see "find more services" if you're
an admin. That will take you to Marketplace.
If you go in as an admin and you look in your
control panel and see add more services, you'll
see a link to the Marketplace there. So we're
trying to drive awareness on the admin. Of
course, admins aren’t always the people
who are shopping for applications but it’s
important to get on their radar. On our product
site, so this is our google.com/app site and
this where we drive--we sign up the majority
of those 3,000 businesses of the day--are
actually coming through this site, learning
about the products, and making a decision
to work with us. So we're going to talk about
our application clearly, and then, we're now
going to be able to talk about your applications
in the Marketplace because we've got this
larger suite we can offer our customers. A
customer emails and webinars--clearly, we
do these things. You know, these are humans.
They have to man--you know, man sessions and
man conference calls. We focus these especially
the webinars around customer success stories.
So telling the story of what you’ve done
with the customer with us is really the key
for us to be able to get out there and tell
specific stories about specific Apps. We also
use AdWords. We are big believers in search
engine marketing. So, for example, in this
case, we run a campaign against the keywords
Google Apps and CRM, we're going to run an
ad that drives traffic to a category in the
Marketplace. In this case, it's a customer
management category. So I need vendors who
are out there in that category or in that
search term can get benefit from their advertising
we're going to do around the Marketplace.
We do blog posts and tweets, all that good
stuff, we've got great--a very nice YouTube
channel. We'd love to have your high quality
video to share. On the home page of the Marketplace
itself, we provide a list--that the latest
two customers' success stories on the homepage
itself. So again, we're really trying to make
it easier for you to, you know, take the investment
to create a customer success story and make
it easy to distribute that to the users that
you want to reach. And one of the ways we
do that is show the latest two stories on
the homepage. And last but not least, the
press. So clearly, the press--we talked to
the press, clearly, they're interested in
the things we're doing, they're interested
in the things you're doing, they're interested
in the things we’re doing together. So,
you know, working together in the Marketplace
from launch on is a great opportunity to engage
the press and tell stories about how we're
helping customers improve their business.
Okay. So enough for me. I'd like to now invite
up Amit, CEO of ManyMoon to tell you a bit
about what they’ve been doing.
>> KULKARNI: Thanks, Scott.
>> MCMULLAN: Thanks, Amit.
>> KULKARNI: Hello. My name is Amit Kulkarni
and I am the co-founder and CEO of ManyMoon.
And today, I'd like to tell you a little bit
about how we became one of the top installed
applications in the Google Apps Marketplace.
So very quickly, what is ManyMoon? ManyMoon
is a social productivity tool that helps people
get work done online with their connections.
Whereas with a lot of other social sites,
you're sharing things like photos and parties
with your friends. With ManyMoon, you're sharing
things like tasks, so managing tasks, completing
projects, sharing Google Docs, whatever you
need to work on. It also has the social capabilities
that people are used to nowadays like profile,
status update, and feeds. But what ManyMoon
has really built into it is the security and
the utility that businesses and professionals
require. So why did we decide to launch on
the Google Apps Marketplace? Well, first and
foremost, as Scott mentioned, it's a huge
market, 25 million users and 2 million businesses.
But what's really exciting is that it's a
fast growing market, over 3,000 businesses
a day. So as a startup, we were really excited
about attaching ourselves to a growing market.
But most importantly, it’s a qualified audience.
So these are businesses and professionals
who we know are willing to pay for SaaS application
and it's a direct pay relationship. So they
will pay you on a monthly or annual basis
for a subscription. The other reason we decided
to launch in the Google Apps Marketplace was,
as a startup, we're always looking to keep
our development cost low and do more with
less. So as I go to the demo, you'll see a
lot of features in ManyMoon that typically
would have taken us months to develop. We
were able to get them done in just days or
weeks by using various Google APIs. And what
that really enables us to do by saving on
development time is very--quicken up our release
cycles which means that we can get more releases
out to customers and get more feedback and
really iterate based on customer feedback.
And as a startup, that’s really our competitive
advantage. So let me go into a demo and show
you how ManyMoon works. So this is a typical
Google Apps user. Her name is Kate and she
works in a company and her manager is saying
that we have to move to a new office at the
end of the month. And she'll turn to ManyMoon
to make this happen. With the contextual gadget
that we just released yesterday, she can,
of course, create a project right here within
her Gmail, a ManyMoon project. But for the
purpose of this demo, what I'll do is actually
go to ManyMoon.com and show you what the product
can do with Google Apps. So first thing, within
the Google universal navigation with one click,
she'll be brought right into the application.
So one of the things we really tried to do
and we developed for Google Apps is reduce
as much of the friction as possible between
the user and them experiencing your application.
So this helped tremendously with conversions.
So now that she's in the application, she's
got a variety of features available to her.
She'll go into a workspace she's already created
called New Office Move and she is going to
assign a task to someone that says select
which office to move to. And again, to reduce
friction, all she has to do is enter in someone's
name. In using the Google context API, we
automatically find people from her address
book and she can assign the task to the person.
Luckily, Kate's also been keeping track of
a list of offices she's been viewing in a
Google spreadsheet that she would like to
attach here, so she'll go to List Google Docs.
ManyMoon will bring up a list of Google Docs
here. So again, as the end-user benefit, all
of the documents and data that she already
has in her Google Apps account, she can reuse
within a third party application and all the
data is still stored and managed by Google.
So she's attached the Google spreadsheet.
She'll say we want to get this task done tomorrow,
and that’s it. By using the Google Doc List
API, ManyMoon automatically shared that Google
spreadsheet with everyone in that work space.
And when people get kicked out of that work
space, ManyMoon resends the data access as
well. So after we released this feature, our
baseline of daily visits increased by 300%
which is tremendous as a startup. Another
feature we had customer shortly after that
asking for was a graphical calendar style
view of everything in their project and workspaces.
So things like open tasks, milestones, meetings,
and what not. Again, this might have taken
us months to build. We were able to do it
in just a couple of weeks by using the Google
Calendar APIs. So I'll go down to project
calendar which is an actuality, just a Google
Calendar that we've automatically shared with
our workspace members and embedded right within
ManyMoon so that task that I automatically
created is already here. The target date for
the project is here as well. So that’s just
a little bit about--I've shown you just a
little bit of what Manymoon can do with Google
apps, and customers really love these integrations.
Since the marketplace launch about two months
ago, we've been signing up on average over
a thousand new businesses every week, just
through the marketplace which is great. But
even better, a large number of these are actually
converting to our premium editions of Manymoon,
so that's Manymoon pro and Manymoon team.
And there are businesses of all sizes that
are upgrading, they're small businesses, large
enterprises, universities, non profits, you
name it. And what the dramatic increase in
revenue really allows us is the ability to
hire more engineers which we're looking to
do, and really execute on our vision which
is really to become the most popular get-work-done
application online. So, a couple of tips that
we learned along the way that I'd like to
share with you on having a successful listing
in the Google apps marketplace, first, it
really starts with your listing page so this
is what people, or domain administrators foresee
when they want to install your app. So, Google
gives you one screenshot to include in your
listing page, we originally included a screenshot
of our user homepage. The issue is that, the
same screenshot is used as thumbnails throughout
the marketplace. So, we found to be much more
effective is to use our logo with stylized
imagery about what our application can do,
so that when people seem to see that thumbnail,
they can immediately understand what your
app can do. Secondly is really organize your
listing page; so, Google gives you free reign
over that. What we did is actually break it
up into a few parts; the first is benefits,
so we very clearly define what are the end-user
benefits to the application. So we talk–-we
don’t talk about features or any technical
aspects, so we talk about ROI, dollar saved,
hour saved, whatever. The second part is features,
and this is a little bit more technical, we
really try to fill this up with our Google
apps specific integration. So how we integrate
with Goggle calendar, how we integrate with
Google docs in different features. And finally,
customer examples; generally, the people who
are coming to your listing page and interested
in your app are domain administrators, and
they really want to know that other customers
have used and validated their application.
So that leads me to the second tip; because
of the nature of the marketplace and who's
actually installing the app, generally is
domain administrators or these business owners,
they really want to know that other customers
are using their app and have other customers
validate your app for you, and the best way
to do that we found is with case studies.
And so, we spend a lot of time talking to
our customers, and talking about what are
the benefits of them Manymoon and Google apps.
So one of the things is really getting a wide
variety of case studies across all sorts of
different industries and businesses. So, we've
got case studies for consultants, property
managers, non profits, event planners, and
that's important because when someone comes
to a listing page, it’s much more effective
if they find out that a similar type of business
is already using your application, they immediately
relate to it. Secondly is account for a lead
time. When we first started case studies,
we thought it might take one or two days and
one phone call, but generally, with these
case studies, it might take a couple of weeks
or even up to a month just to go to the customer
approval cycle. So really, it’s important
to have a good pipeline of customers who are
willing to help you out with case studies.
Secondly, use Google's format and the URL
below, Google's got a very nice format for
case studies that you can use, and that includes
one paragraph about the customer, one paragraph
about your business, a problem statement,
a solution statement, and then one or two
paragraphs about the results and benefits
of using Manymoon plus Google apps. And so,
we use it as sort of our standard case study
template now. Most importantly we think is
selecting one key metric for your application
and your customer's business, to use in all
of your case studies. So for us as a social
productivity tool, we really try to focus
on how many emails we're saving either per
user, per month, per project, per week, per
whatever. And we try to include that metric
in every case study and also include it in
every customer quote where possible in every
case study. And then finally, publish in Market
year case studies; so of course in the URL
below, Google's got a very easy to use web
form where you could submit the case studies,
we also post them on our own website, we blog
about them, and we tweet about them. And really-–and
also you can even get out to different industry
webpages and have customers talk about them.
So those are just a couple of tips, I hope
that helps, and I’ll turn it over to Chuck
of SlideRocket.
>> I am Chuck with SlideRocket and I'm going
to tell you about why we joined the market
place and some of the benefits; and in doing
so, also get to show you our application.
So, what we're focused on is reinventing presentations;
and as you guys know, there's a lot of presentations
made, there's over 500 million copies of PowerPoint
out in the market, there's over 40 million
presentation delivered a day, who knows how
many are delivered here at IO today, and unfortunately,
a lot of them are pretty bad. And they're
bad for two reasons; one, sometimes they're
just bullet points, and they're really boring,
and you got to suffer through them; but the
other side to them is putting them together
is laborious. You probably re-create the same
slide someone else has already created, you
can't find slides you've already created,
once you need to distribute them, they're
tough to distribute, it's tough to get people
collaborate on them, and you have no idea
what people are doing with them; are they
opening them, are they viewing them, and if
you ever want to update them, it’s very
difficult to pull them back from websites,
or from emails that you've distributed. So
what we focused on is reinventing that whole
process and we look at presentations as kind
of a life cycle, where creation is just one
step of it. The other step is collaborating;
so inviting people from other organizations
to build slides that might automatically flow
into your presentation, having only to manage
those dynamically. So, the content is actually
updated dynamically from other data sources,
and this is one of the most interesting things
that we're doing with the marketplace. Abilities
to share them publicly, securely embed them
on pages, and then get detailed analytics
in what people are doing with those; are your
prospects opening them? Are they forwarding
them around to other decision makers? And
this is a perfect chance to jump out of our
application and just kind of show you how
this works really quick. So, I'm now in kind
of the SlideRocket editor and if I wanted
to create a presentation for Google IO, what
I do is just go into the SlideRockets slide
library, I do a search for slides that were
tagged Google, and I would drag in and drop
the symbol of presentation that might be relevant
for this audience, for the message we're trying
to convey, and it's very likely that other
people in my organization like my marketing
manager is keeping up these up to date so,
they're always live and dynamically updated,
and always represent kind of our best message.
So, I'll close the library here, and jump
back into play. So, why we partnered with
Google was, their customers are our customers.
I mean, it’s rare you're going to find someone
who's got 25 million users and 3,000 new businesses
a day. And these customers buy Google for
the same reason, they buy SlideRocket, they
believe online and in the cloud is faster,
cheaper, quicker, and what we look at our
self is, is an extension of the Google apps.
So we focus, you know, very deeply on the
presentation area to provide an experience
that is better than something they can get
with packaged software. And then our initial
integration, we focused on four areas; and
Google opens up a lot of API's so you can
do a lot of connections, but we focus on these
four integrations for our first launch into
the marketplace. First is of course the single
sign on, and I'll talk about that in the next
slide, I think that's the most powerful thing
for the marketplace, or one of the most powerful
things. Single sign on; it seems very simple,
but it has a lot of ramifications n terms
of user provisioning. Second is the ability
to take content from Google like Google presentations
and import it into SlideRocket, third is dynamically
updating content in SlideRocket, slides, tables,
graphs from data that resides in Google apps,
and then of course, using the Google contact
as a management for how you distribute to
people in your organization, people in your
university sales prospects etcetera. So, let's
talk about what the marketplace is meant for
us; this graph on your left here shows a huge
spike in traffic we had as a result of the
launch on the 9th. The graph on the right
here isn’t populated yet, but what I wanted
to show you is a quick demo of how we connect
to Google data to populate, dynamically populate
tables and charts. So if I click on this table
and chart, now thanks to our marketplace integration,
I can link to Google spreadsheets here. In
linking to Google spreadsheets, it’s recognizing
who I am, and it’s pulling up a list of
all the Google spreadsheets I have access
to. What I want to talk to you about here
is how we've seen an increase in the user
growth as a result of our marketplace. I'm
going to check this box which is going to
keep my graph dynamically updated, so every
time the spreadsheet changes, the graph's
going to change, and the information that
I'm conveying is going to always be up to
date, and then I'll shift in the play mode
here again, and what you see here is something
really phenomenal after our marketplace launch
and again thanks to the single sign on provisioning,
it used to be that, when someone would come
to our website, it'd be one user at a company
and that sign up for trial, and they'd kick
the tires on SlideRocket, if they'd like it,
they tell some other people in the organization.
But with that add-it button which Scott showed
you, they can add it for every single user
in their organization. So we saw the number
of people in our trials go up 500% and that
gives us an in chance not just to engage with
one person in the organization who wants to
try out SlideRocket, but it gives us a vehicle
to speak to all of the users in that organization
and greatly increases the likelihood of a
conversion, in an adopted customer, so that
was a huge benefit to the market place for
us. A second big benefit and Scott spoke about
this briefly, is Google has a lot of marketing
might and what we see is they’re putting
a lot of energy and a lot of people and resources
behind our enterprise division and behind
the marketplace. And that by partnering with
them, there's a lot of different marketing
opportunities that you can take advantage
of to increase the size and the awareness
of your company. And this is just a quick
summary of the five things we thought were
most importantly. One is your marketplace
listing, folks spoke about that already, two,
is there's a YouTube channel for--focused
a lot on the marketplace and enterprise used
cases. So, you can create case studies, you
can create how-to videos on how your product
works with Google apps, and you can syndicate
that out on Google's YouTube Channel, and
that's going to bring a lot of viewership
and awareness to your application. Two is
the social of course; there's people, you
know, could be tweeting here right now associating
SlideRocket with Google, and that brings a
lot of followers back to our site; so again,
a very powerful. PR, Google sneezes, you know,
tech crunch has taken over about Google sneeze.
So, Google has an unbelievable amount of awareness
in the press, and as an example here, we put
together a press release on our Google announcement.
So, we’re looking into SlideRocket again
here and we sent this press release which
is a presentation out to 200 reporters, you
know, we don’t typically get this sort of
following with our press releases, but these
200 reporters forwarded it to 1200 other folks,
and we can see where they're opening and where
they're spending their time. So, it just goes
to show that when you associate your company
with Google, you get a lot more awareness
that you might on your own. And then of course,
customer case studies; so, building these
case studies, Google is looking for enterprise
customer case studies to promote, you can
find customers that use your product in conjunction
with Google, and feed those up to Google,
and they can put them on their blogs and start
syndicating that and again, build an awareness
for you. So quick summary; four points here.
One is build it quickly. Google invited us
to be a launch partner; it took two of our
developers one weekend to build what you saw
here. So if you're thinking about joining
the market place, I'll encourage you to just
stop thinking about it and just--just get
in there and try it. Two is it extends the
functionality of your application. So we didn't
want to build a spreadsheet tool, to populate
tables and charts. We don't want to build
a contact management. We don't want to build
calendar things. So you can actually increase
the scope and the function--features and functionality
of your product by taking advantage of this
market place API integrations. Three is the
marketing cache that Google offers which we
spoke about already. And then fourth is you
guys might know Google has a lighter weight
presentation on-line authoring tool. Google's
been extremely supportive of our kind of more
robust system which looks beyond authoring
around the whole life cycle so, if you have
a little bit of overlap with any Google functionality,
I would not let that discourage you from building.
They've been a great partner and we look forward
to continued success with the marketplace.
So with that I'll hand it over to Jay.
>> SIMONS: Thanks Chuck. I feel like a sprinter
at the end of a relay. They probably put me
last because I'm the fastest talker. My name
is Jay, I'm from--I'm from Atlassian. Atlassian
is a maker of software development and collaboration
tools. We're an Australian company with people
scattered around Sydney, San Francisco and
Amsterdam in Europe. We have a portfolio of
eight products, our flagship products include
hopefully a couple that you've heard of JIRA
which is a popular issue in bug tracker and
conference which is a popular Wiki. We also
have a collection of developer tools. They're
really focused on code collaboration around
source-code reviews, continuous integration,
code coverage and quality, with about 17,000
customers worldwide. Our fastest growing product
is a product called JIRA Studio, which combines
our entire portfolio into a hosted development
suite for not just developers but the people
that are part of a technical team, building
software together. And we saw the Google apps
marketplace is a great opportunity to provide
a compliment to Google's messaging and collaboration
tools to developers of Google apps customers.
And--and certainly there are a lot of those.
So in the middle, we describe the capabilities
that JIRA Studio offers. Hosted subversion
for source control, bug tracking, code browsing,
a wiki agile planning, continuous integration,
and code reviews. We saw that as a great compliment
to the messaging and collaboration tools in
Google apps. So let me click over and give
you a quick demonstration of some of the integration
that we've built. We're going to actually
start our demo in Gmail, because a lot of
us, whether we like it or not, spend a lot
of time cleaning out our inboxes. I'm logged--I'm
logged in here as a tech lead and a tech lead
might spend a little bit less time than most
of us in email. But still he or she might
start their day cleaning up the inbox. To
the left of the Gmail inbox is a gadget that's
actually showing issues from JIRA Studio that
are assigned to me as a tech lead. So I see
at the bottom here, one of the issues is a
truly incredible feature that the development
team is going to work on together. And at
the heart of JIRA Studios sits JIRA, because
a lot of development tasks are built around
issues or bugs that we're trying to fix. Rather
than click on an issue which I could do, from
Google's universal navigation, I want to select
JIRA Studio and actually take you to the front
page of--of JIRA Studio just to give you a
quick snapshot of--of what's in the box. Across
the top, you sort of see the key components
of JIRA Studio. This is the front of JIRA
Studio, which is a dashboard. Technology behind
the dashboard is gadgets and it's the same
gadget technology that Google gadgets is using.
So as you saw in the previous screen, gadgets
from JIRA Studio can be added to Google applications,
like Gmail or GCaP or Google sites. Conversely,
Google gadgets can be added to my studio dashboard,
like the gadget here, Google Translate. Dashboard
sort of gives me a snapshot of information
across my project from other developers or
members of the technical team. So I have an
activity stream, this is the gadget that we
saw in the previous screen with issues that
are assigned to me. I can see statistics around
source-code activity in the source-code repository.
Changed sets, open pew reviews, et cetera.
Again because most of the development happens
around issues, actually I want to click on
the issue that I mentioned earlier, this truly
incredible feature and I see that developments
actually waiting for the design specification.
So one of the integration points that JIRA
Studio has with Google apps, we've integrated
with Google docs API, similar to Manymoon.
In this case, the design specification has
been collaborated on with the technical team
or product management and it's a Google doc.
Really quickly I can assemble a list of docs.
I selected the one that I want to attach to
the issue and then development can begin.
Down at the bottom, we see what we refer to
as the JIRA Studio activity bar. And it's
another key integration point between JIRA
Studio and Google apps. They really sort of
fuses the two systems together. So on the
left, we have provide to users of JIRA Studio,
kind of fingertip access to information across
all the tools that are comprised between JIRA
Studio and Google apps. So I can see is an
example, open cover views that are assigned
to this user, the tech lead. I get a snapshot
of email and from Gmail, I can see if there's
any important messages that I want to click
into directly as opposed to having to switch
contacts entirely to go to Gmail. You can
also see access to my calendar in Google sites.
Another feature that we felt we wanted to
take advantage of was integrating Google talk.
And Google talk really gave us the ability
to add instant messaging almost as a native
feature of Google suit or JIRA Studio itself.
So chat and instant messaging is a core way
for developers interacts with another. Now
it's pervasive across the entire hosted development
suite. So here quickly in this issue page,
I can send a message to another developer
and say design spec is attached and even include
a hyper link to the page, so they can quickly
see that it's there. I can then, if I wanted
to go to Google calendar and maybe add a 3PM
design spec review meeting with Dan, again
without ever leaving JIRA Studio. So that's
kind of a quick glimpse of very small number
of features that we integrated with Google
apps. How has it gone for us? Really, really
well. Since launch, we've seen a 30 % at increase
in sales of JIRA Studio. Wrong screen--and
we've also doubled the amount of traffic that
we're driving to JIRA Studios home page on
our website, and so--so far, so good. Here
is a couple of tips that I'll end with. Similar
to what Amit said from Manymoon in addition
to really focusing on the listing page which
you need to really represent your product
in the marketplace, you have to think very
carefully about the landing page on your website.
We're driving a lot of interest in the integration
between JIRA Studio and Google apps from within
our network. And we also have to think carefully
about the handoff between the listing page,
which has kind of a snapshot of information
and the broader webpage that might describe
the feature set in your products. In our landing
page, we've also added the add-the-Google-domain
button. So it feels like there's an opportunity
to quickly trial the product from wherever
you land. The final tip from me is also just
about thinking carefully how to engage the
broader set of users, reviews are an important
part of helping other evaluators in the market
place, understand whether your product is
successful or popular or liked by users. And
rather than just engage the administrator
of the evaluator, we also wanted to think
about how to engage potentially the dozens
of developers that are using our products.
We want to think very carefully about this
but basically after 10 hours of usage, we
have a subtle little dialog box that'll pop
up and say, you seem to be liking JIRA studio.
If you do like it, we'd love for you to pay
it forward or share the joy on the Google
market place. And anytime you can dismiss
this forever, it's just a one time sort of
subtle request for support. With that, that’s
us from Atlassian and I'll hand it back over
to Scott, I think, for Q&A.
>> MCMULLAN: Thanks guys. Awesome. And your
paying cash should be a little bit bigger
now, so thank you for those endorsements.
Just kidding. Okay, so, we'll see if we can
get some love from the moderator here inside
of Wave. Let's see here, these are notes,
each time we have about 15 minutes. So, I
admit to being a little of a newbie with Moderator
and Wave. So, why don’t we, unless someone
has [INDISTINCT]
>> KULKARNI: Little bit right now.
>> MCMULLAN: Loading. So, while we're loading,
anyone wants to shout out a question, comment,
why don’t we just go live, old style. Anyone
have any questions for the folks up here or
my self on what you’ve heard. Go ahead.
>> Anyway, I have one. Thank you very much
for your presentation. My first question actually
is regarding the security. So, right now,
Google, when you buy, Google apps commit that
they secure datas, what about you guys? Do
you secure our datas the same way that Google
does?
>> KULKARNI: Yeah. So, we have a page where
we talk about our security practices but what's
really important is the way we integrate with
Google apps is all that your Google data is
still stored and managed by Google, so that
security is still maintained with them. So,
the credentials that you use to log in to
Manymoon are actually stored and managed by
Google. We don’t have access to them, same
with your Google docs, same with your Google
calendar. So, that’s one of the benefits
of being on the Marketplace as you take advantage
of Google security practices.
>> Thanks.
>> MCMULLAN: I would just follow up that,
you know, any cloud provider, any application
provider out there certainly has this question
from customers and challenges. So, it’s,
you know, it's part of the DNA of a software
and service company to treat the data right,
keep it secure.
>> Thanks a lot.
>> MCMULLAN: Yup?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MCMULLAN: So, in general, you, as a vendor,
get to choose whatever business model, trial
model, et cetera you want. We, as Google,
only show revenue when you have a customer
who converts to a paying account. So, if there
are free--premium product and they get take
a year to convert then there's nothing between
us until they actually start paying.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> MCMULLAN: So, two parts the answer. Today,
it's actually; you have full control of it
as if you were selling directly. When we introduce
our payment options and our payment APIs and
flow, then you will have a choice to figure
out yes if you want to take payment upfront,
again, if you want to do it--engage in a trial,
you'll get to essentially create those payment
events and you use the billing API to basically
power to check out and pay the process when
that event occurs.
>> So sorry. Last one. So, today, once I pay,
do they give the credit card to me or to you?
>> MCMULLAN: Today because we're kind of in
a post-launch state, we don’t have the full
payment infrastructure set in live, they actually
pay you.
>> And then you trust me to give you the 20%?
>> MCMULLAN: Now, we're in
a red share free mode right now. So basically,
everything that you sell between now and when
we re-launch our payment system, is yours
to keep. Yeah.
>> Hi there. One of the questions I had was,
I've seen the Google mail contextual gadgets
but I'm interested in sort of
the interest there is on the part of the Google
apps team to open up the interface of the
app themselves for tighter integration. So,
for example, you know, adding menus and things
like that inside of Google docs or [INDISTINCT]
or whatever else. Is that--is that in the
plans? Are you guys thinking about it? Is
that something…
>> We--it’s a great idea. We want to hear
those kind of requests. We definitely get,
for example, I think Chuck, your team asked
us, hey, we'd love the get a menu in your
Google docs, can we make that happen. So,
we're definitely, you know, customer driven.
So the more you request that and where you
help us figure out what the value is for you,
the better it is for us to figure out in terms
of roadmap.
>> Thanks.
>> MCMULLAN: Soon, have you got some of the
docs, pms in the audience so.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MCMULLAN: You can do it today with appscript
and spreadsheets. So, awesome. Go ahead.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> MCMULLAN: Sure.
>> MCMULLAN: The question is how do we vets
(ph) the listings in the new app that come
in especially around security. So, we have
a light weight screening process to actually
list the Marketplace. It's not--it's not based
on a security review, it’s based on you
following the fairly transparent and simple
steps of meeting requirements. And it’s
definitely up to you to, you know, again to
protect your users' data just as you do normally.
We do really try to make it transparent to
the buyer both before they're buying and the
listing we list all the different APIs you're
going to want access to and of course, during
that check out process where the admin go
to make that grant, you know, they’ll be--you
can't add--you can't get access to things
that you haven’t asked for and explicitly
told the user about.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> MCMULLAN: That’s a great questions. The
question is if you're not--not an admin and
you're in the Marketplace and you find something
you like, how do you let your administrator
know? That’s on our--on our list of things.
We definitely want to make that easier. Any
more questions for these guys? Go ahead at
the mic.
>> I was wondering whether you support user's
based payments. Not every business model works
on a flat fee per month. So, do you have any
plans to introduce that in the future with
your payment system?
>> User based pricing?
>> Yes, well actually, I was thinking…
>> MCMULLAN: A usage?
>> Usage base. See, take a phone service.
You may wrack up a different phone bill every
month. Do you have a solution to that?
>> MCMULLAN: So, we definitely plan to accommodate
that. We've looked--we've spent a lot of time,
you know, looking at the diverse models, that
our 50 launch partners plus other folks who
have come since then, you know, how are they
charging their customer's user usage, time,
et cetera. It's challenge to accommodate all
those, but our goal is definitely to accommodate
all the different pricing models that you
want to use as a vendor. And so, details--you
know, TBD in terms of how the APIs going to
make that happen but the answer is yes. We’re
looking at that.
>> I have a question for the providers. So,
do you see your value as providing more of
the work flow through? For a specific customer
set, that kind of water bugs on top of the
data API? Or is it more about specializing
in the actual data? Because you're not really
holding the data, you're pocketing it in the
Google infrastructure.
>> DIETRICH: It might vary for the different
applications. For us at SlideRocket, it's
twofold. Its one, people live in Gmail. Google
Apps users live in Gmail. If we can make our
app discoverable with a single click from
Gmail, it increases the adoption, so one is
adoption. Two is as I mentioned is we look
at Google as having a great suite of functionally
that we didn’t want to have build ourselves.
So through the Marketplace, we were able to
integrate and extend the functionality of
our applications such as the spreads--spreadsheets,
I mentioned, how we could link it dynamically
to grasp the table and we look forward to
doing to that with things with like Google
Buzz, buzz feeds into presentation so, two
main reasons for us, I'm sure if you guys
have…
>> SIMONS: Well, I mean we offer tools that
Google doesn’t offer and as I mentioned--I
mean, their developers, inside of companies
is using Google Apps. And we think that the
experience of having their development tools
connected to the messaging collaboration tools
that they're using for Google is a better
one for them and its going to save them time.
>> So are they comfortable then with like
coming back and modifying spreadsheets that
your application may have created or set permissions
on? Than to, kind of, go out and see those
kind of behind the scenes and the spreadsheet,
and then see the implementation as it's viewed
through your app?
>> DIETRICH: Yes, that’s correct. So, it's
people with the right permissions as it is
designated by Google Spreadsheets. Modify
those spreadsheets or those spreadsheets are
modified from data feeds that that user might
have connected to Google Spreadsheets that
automatically feeds the visual representation
of that spreadsheet in SlideRocket.
>> Thanks.
>> Hi. I guess this is a question to Scott.
You--I think you mention that a Google checkout
would become required, once you're out of
the revenue free phase. How does that work
then with our payment [INDISTINCT] ways that
we have set-up currently, will we have to
keep those for our other customers and go
with Google Checkout only for Google Marketplace
users?
>> MCMULLAN: So--Yes, the payment flow that
you've got today and maybe from a repayment
processor, you'll need to hook-in essentially
your pricing engine and the kind of the checkout
step with our APIs.
>> For all users, even those that come through
the open Marketplace, not yours?
>> MCMULLAN: You can definitely have both
flows but for our users who come in and they--for
example they have a checkout account, they
may purchase other apps, Marketplace apps,
they've got kind of a nice single invoice--you
know, bill every month or every year. You
know, they're going to want to use those credentials
to purchase your app. And you can definitely,
obviously, maintain your other flows as well.
Great.
>> Hi. Are you considering in the payment
when you sell not one time, but as a service
perhaps a monthly service. Are you considering
it in the payment in the Marketplace?
>> MCMULLAN: Yes, absolutely. We assume that
almost everyone is using some sort of recurring
billing whether it's monthly or, you know,
based on what usage they have to fill back
up. So it's definitely the--in the DNA of
most of the company like us. It's an annual
subscription for our products. The question
are we considering it for--do we, do we share
revenue during that?
>> Yes and how [INDISTINCT] in the future…
>> MCMULLAN: Yes, it’s a recurring. It's
for the lifetime of the customer.
>> Okay.
>> MCMULLAN: Yes. It's not a--it's not a onetime
fee.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. I guess this is, this is for
Manymoon.
>> MCMULLAN: I think, last question here.
Thank you.
>> Can I ask it?
>> MCMULLAN: Absolutely. Please. Sorry.
>> For Manymoon, I think like the projects
that, you know--a custom (ph) that this 25
million users can start Manymoon--the collaborators
are those only inside the 25 million or--because
projects often access across enterprise boundaries.
>> KULKARNI: Yes, so you know. One of the
benefits of being a SaaS Application is it
can work outside of the firewall as well.
So Manymoon as an application, it was built
from the ground up to support the Internet,
so email addresses. So you can invite into
any project or workspace as long as you have
their email address, but we integrate with
iGoogle Contacts API, it's all those contacts
you have already whether they're inside of
your domain or outside. You can start collaborating
with them.
>> Great, thanks.
>> MCMULLAN: All right. Well, I want to thank
Jay and Chuck, and Amit for joining me today.
And thank you all for being--attending the
session. Thanks.